le jinsan à 5 folioles a fait la fortune
d'exportateur au XVIIIe siècle au point
de presse qui disparaître à l'état
sauvage mais on trouve cette espèce
menacée ici on n'a pas besoin d'être
biologiste
pour comprendre qu'on est dans un milieu
extraordinaire nous sommes sur le flanc
sud du mont Saint-Bruno à une vingtaine
de kilomètres de Montréal le boisé des
hirondelles qui couvrent 6 hectares à
partir depuis 2006 au sénateur Paul
massicott qui voulait y construire une
vingtaine de maisons
a toujours été protégé même avant que le
promoteur en fasse l'acquisition de la
forêt des hirondelles ce qui a été
modifié si au niveau de la
réglementation municipale alors la ville
adoptée en 2018 une réglementation qui
entre cadre la coupe d'arbre dans ces
milieux naturels d'intérêt ce qui vaut à
la ville d'être poursuivi en cours
supérieure pour expropriation déguisée
le nouveau maire veut protéger la petite
forêt
avec le propriétaire donc ça m'est
prestige afin d'acquérir le boisé des
hirondelles malheureusement on n'a pas
pu s'entendre et c'est sur 4 boisés on a
tenté d'acquérir dans la dernière année
c'est le seul propriétaire avec lequel
on a pas pu s'entendre
[Musique]
un milieu qui est en sursis en attendant
la décision du tribunal ici Mathieu pros
Radio-Canada saint Bruno de montar